hey Doug Walker here I just saw the nun
and before I go into it I should
probably tell you my thoughts on the
other conjuring movies this is a prequel
to one of them the second one I think
there's so many of these now so first
film I didn't like I'm one of those
assholes that didn't like it I thought I
was boring if I was dumb based on a true
story my ass
I thought the scares were predictable
the only thing I thought was good was I
like that but everything else I thought
was stupid and forgettable and then just
really lame never saw the second one
though after the opening they showed in
this one that showed a few clips from it
now the little interests I might want to
check that out I never saw Annabel I saw
was shit I heard it was shit but I did
see an about creation and I liked that I
completely forgot about it after I saw
it but while I was watching it I really
really enjoyed it so now we have the nun
and it's kind of like Annabel creation
where while I was watching it I was
legitimately enjoying I liked the
atmosphere I liked the characters I
thought it was visually it was great
this is kind of like the old school you
know universal monster films there's a
lot of smoke and fog on the ground
there's a lot of cemeteries and
tombstones and these gothic buildings
and churches and stuff and I loved all
that I absolutely love that and I don't
see that much in movies in horror films
they're mostly like well the conjuring
they're mostly like just these scary
dark houses and they look very bland and
just things are peeling and just jump
scares and and very dull but this one
had a real visual eye in had for the
most part likable characters it's pretty
much about there's a suicide at this
church back in the 1950s and I think was
a Romanian I think and they send in a
priest from the Vatican up it's a really
great line or he says you look like you
don't trust me and he's like well it's
the Vatican it that's a great line but
so they send him and they send this nun
or nun in training who's supposed to be
actually white did please
Oh cuz I guess you got these visions
sometimes so they think that might help
so it's like a psychic nun or something
it's stories pretty ridiculous so they
go out there and they come across this
guy who's gonna be the guide he's he's
very much like the Brendan Fraser
character from the newer I guess they're
not new anymore but from The Mummy
movies except a lot more likeable and
he's called Frenchie and he takes him
there and it's like all those
traditional setups of like these old
Universal movies where they're like they
got the little cart with the horse and
there's the giant building on the you
know on the hill and everything and the
fog and I love this stuff this is just
100% up my alley
and it takes its time a little bit too
it's not something where there's a lot
of forced humor or a lot of I don't know
just shoved in your face dialogue it's
actually really kind of taking its time
and letting the atmosphere kind of sit
there's not a lot of there's not a lot
of fake outs like you know someone just
says oh it's just me or you know nothing
like that so that's also really nice and
then obviously the stuff starts to
happen there there in this church or
Hogwarts it looks like honestly and
they're all these nuns are popping up
and then they're disappearing and
they're trying to figure out why there's
one dude at one point is like buried
alive and and the nun has to go and get
them out everything so I mean so all
these crazy things are happening and for
the most part it it works fine for what
this is except for one it's your problem
I mean there's stuff like the story is
dumb but I mean like everybody knows
that going in it's not insultingly dumb
it's just your run-of-the-mill dumb it's
you know everyday average horror film
dumb but there was one big problem uh it
is not scary at all I think I can think
of two scenes that legit got kind of a
creep value it kind of a creep out of me
what is one the guy he's going through
the cemetery and for a split second his
life flashes behind you see like this
little boy
looking behind this tombstone a flashes
back it's not there and it's so quick
that you kind of you're not even sure if
you saw it like that's one of those
scenes where it's like I like to go back
and pause and look at that and see yeah
what did I see there I like stuff like
that um and and there's an AR scene
where like this nun she's got a sheet
over her and she's you know dead and the
nuns about to say a prayer and something
happens that just caught me by surprise
I'm like oh that was it good
I was good jump-scare um everything else
it's they're not bad they're not like I
said they're not like insultingly bad or
come on you know that's that was so lame
because I think we've all seen work
films that do that uh but these these
tricks are becoming very very standard
now there's something in the background
camera turns this way when it comes back
somebody's gonna be behind them and the
purse is slowly gonna turn around but
that's not gonna do something something
from the right is gonna do something or
something from you know in front or
behind you know it's it's never where
they're making it look like it's gonna
be it's gonna be from the opposite side
and it's becoming very very standard now
with that said I much rather have that
than something like just a slasher film
where like somebody's there and just
kills him and oh no and that's very very
boring to me unless again you do like
something creative like happy deathday
or something like that you know was
creative with that idea but yeah so it's
one of those things where there is kind
of like it's okay build up it's okay
kind of creepiness and the visuals in
this are very nice you know it's kind of
like especially in the climax the climax
has a lot of I can only describe them as
like the Hellfire robed people it's like
the Hellfire robe people just as nuns
you know where you don't see the faces
and there's once you watch if you see
this movie that this fire rises up
you're not supposed to see their faces
and one of them you can clearly see like
it's just wearing one of those black
mask we can kind of see the eyes and the
nose outlined I was just like the
digital artist missed that because you
know that wasn't intentional um how
about the creepiness of this is kind of
like how Lord of
rings is creepy you know like the ring
race or when Frodo falls in that swamp
of the Dead whatever and say it's that
kind of imagery so if that scares you
this will scare you but it's the same
kind of idea I almost feel like this
thing takes place in like you know
Mordor or something like that like it
just got like the Scimitar afee is kind
of like them the colors are very much
like then the monsters and creatures are
very much like that and the plot is
essentially like calling this demon nun
the night because they really take a lot
from demon night
there's this plot about like this whole
Easter egg that holds like you know the
blood of Christ and only this can stop
you know the evil forces from coming up
and taking over the world and it does
have a climax where somebody spits in
somebody's face with the blood I mean
it's something where it's it it's not
giving anything away I mean you can
it gets pretty pretty obvious but but
it's one of those movies to where it's
like the the main bad nun you know the
one you see in the posters and
everything kind of looks like a Batman
villain near the end I mean it starts to
look pretty goofy and like you know
she's trying to possess you know this
other person and you know the other
person has the Easter Egg you know
around her neck and you think as soon as
she's like got this body soon she's in
control like she would just throw that
thing she would just destroy her gift
but it's like no she's got to go and
like take care of this guy who she can
easily defeat and of course he uses that
to the advantage it kind of it turns
into kind of the mummy movies but but
like the opening of The Mummy movies not
the later have where it's like you know
us an even more silly evil dead um so it
it is dumb but it's not insultingly dumb
it visually looks great the like at
least the two main characters uh the nun
in training and this Frenchie guy are
really likable and they're sort of what
carry me through though Frenchie
disappears throughout a good chunk of it
the other guy the other main character
is this priest and he is super boring
and I
don't know if it's his performance or
the Wiis written they give me this
backstory about this boy he exercised
and it just unless I missed something
you did seem like you went anywhere and
it just seemed like well we just need
some other creepy visuals outside of
just these damn nuns and it and it's not
scary and it doesn't really tell me
anything about him so anything with him
was pretty dull but everything else it's
a very run-of-the-mill scary movie but I
think it delivers for the most part
where you're gonna be looking for I
think some people might be let down that
the scares are not that great or you're
just you're expecting them too much now
because the crowd I saw with I saw with
a crowd that like kind of the crowd you
want to see this with where they talk
through the movie and I usually don't
like that but in some films it's okay it
depends on the film it depends on the
people and this was the right film and
there's a dude these were the right
people I mean these were the people
there watching the the trailer for the
new Halloween movie and as soon as like
you see Michael Myers you know coming up
behind this woman these this family
behind it's just like get her get her
just like get that bit oh yeah we got
that bitch yeah I got that I knew I was
gonna get that bitch and it's like I
loved listening to these people
and they kind of knew when to be quiet
during the quieter moments and when to
just do the you know oh shit hell no
like that kind of stuff so every once in
a while when something would appear
behind the main character you know there
just be oh shit Jesus God do you know
like there'd be something like that but
but there wasn't a lot of ah like when
the thing actually came out and showed
its Gary face or attacked whatever there
was not a lot of screaming there was not
a lot of uh you know jumping in there
and like I said I think we're just kind
of becoming a little bit more used to it
and this is a movie designed to get that
react it wants you to jump it wants you
to scream and it wants you to do it
not at the fake-out moment I can't
really remember any fake-out moments
which I'm very thankful for but yeah I
don't know
maybe they just need some even scarier
preachers or nuns or demons or something
to be going after them or maybe just we
need something different than the things
behind them and it's getting closer and
the person slowly turns and then
something from the other end attacks you
know it's that's just getting old but
but I will say this early on I saw a
movie with my wife and when in the end
the beginning particularly there's a
really great set up some of these setups
are good where you know that this nun
hanged herself and this guy's French a
guy found her so he's taking them to the
nun that killed herself and we opens the
door there too you know she's sitting up
there the body and everything and then
they're gonna go inspect and he says I
should let you know that is not how I
left her
I left her laying down and like nobody
else is there and it's like that that's
a wonderful setup so as soon as those
guys getting closer to the nun you know
and you know everyone's like that and he
gets close and you again you know this
setup here's here's the nun and somebody
over here says something and he turns
this as please I know what I'm doing and
my wife just would like that like
squeezing my hand like here it comes and
it didn't happen and there's a couple
moments like that where they're making
it look like we're gonna do that shtick
and then they don't and that gave me a
lot of Hope because I first I'm like
alright so so you are gonna do something
a little different but then they just
kind of they do the stuff that every
other horror film right now is doing you
know so it's not something where it's
like this is super tired and super just
you know decades of this going on I mean
this is like the past maybe six seven
years of this like high to becoming
standard this is stuff where I me a
couple decades ago we said we wish
horror films would do this now they're
all doing this so which is tricky
because then you have to come up with
different things and different ways to
get scares so so I get it stuff but
that's probably the biggest problem with
this film everything else in terms of
like a compelling story and the
like that I mean it's you know you're
not gonna get that I mean these
conjuring movies are stupid but if they
can be done you know just to get a few
scares and you like the characters and
and you're with them as you're getting
through this stuff I think it's what
people are looking for I think it's why
Annabel creation worked okay but again I
I it's hard to remember anything about
it I just remember I liked it while
watching it had some good scares and I'm
just like but if you to tell me name
three or four scares in that movie I
couldn't wear with this one at least I
remember the atmosphere a lot I remember
the environment and I'll remember these
characters uh these were the two main
ones anyway we're really really good
characters and I enjoyed them and I want
to see them get out alive so yeah I feel
like people going to see this film know
what they're gonna go see and they'll
probably get what they're looking for I
think just the scares for this kind of
film it could have been stronger than
something needs to be upped if these
films are gonna keep going I'm Amy
something else needs to there needs to
be a different way even if their jump
scares and I usually don't like jump
scares but like I said we've gotten a
little better at them in a sense it's
like they're still cheap but we've got a
little bit more creative with them you
know uh it the film version of it had a
lot of jump scares but but they were
creative that there was a creativity to
a man like that they're doing that uh
but this feels like that creativity is
really losing steam and I'd like to see
them try something different
um you know just some something new with
it I don't know I will also say because
I think the nun is in the conjuring - I
don't remember one the conjuring one and
they made a connection at the conjuring
- I don't know at the end they do make a
connection - and I can tell this is for
you from the first conjuring or the
second one and I don't know if it's like
what that destroys everything we knew
about that film I don't know it's like
there is a connection I know it's a
slight connection but I don't know if it
ruins anything I don't know if I don't
know how seriously people take the
mythos of this because it's all true
story guys but you're not gonna find out
much about the none either this is a
prequel you don't know shit about this
monster which is a incus it's a cool
idea ever ever since I saw that nun at
the end of vertigo there's always I've
always been likewise in there a creepy
nun movie and finally we got one and
sometimes they do look creepy but yeah
like I said they kind of look more like
Batman villains I don't know like I said
I think just because these tricks have
been done so many times and we're just
so used to them but but like I said if
you're just looking for if you want to
see this film if you look at the
trailers and say I want to see this film
um you know you're not getting anything
terrifying but you'll get a totally okay
popcorn eating jump scare movie you know
the witch has some good characters some
nice visuals is a great atmosphere with
with like the cemeteries and the
landscapes and the hills and mountains
and stuff like that and the architecture
very gothic I love that stuff if that's
what you're looking for but you're gonna
love the atmosphere in this but it's
nothing special it's I think it's anyone
to go see this wolf for the most part
yet what they're looking for
and if I think it goes without saying if
you're looking for like a high-end good
story telling scary film it's gonna last
years and years this isn't it this is
just sit down eat your popcorn go out
and that's it that's what you're looking
for yeah it'll totally fulfill what
they'll only fulfill that so that's
about it and I shall see you next time
take care
you